ok this is the order flows trade
analysis for friday jun 17 2016 my name
is michael altos i'm the founder and
trader at order flows calm first a brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only and should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make any other type of
investment decision future training
contains substantial risk and is not for
every investor and investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that can be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading and only those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past performance it's not necessarily
indicative of future results okay so the
three tools that are used in this
presentation are the order flows trader
it's the main software that I developed
as well as a couple indicators order
flows Delta scalper and the order close
price rejecter you can go to my website
WWF lowes com to learn more about it and
all my software runs on the NinjaTrader
trading platform to learn more about
ninja trader visit ninjatrader com okay
so my first trade was in the email ease
it was on the five range chart and we
just come into our low we had a
divergence right off the low here you
didn't have a ratio that I like you know
just as you had a divergence a few bars
earlier but also we got this nice buying
a balance for levels deep right off the
low it really looked to me as if the
market was ready to take off you know
yet very strong Delta hear positive 2559
so I got long along the inside here at
63 and three-quarters I was looking for
a move up around the 66 level and you
know we started going there we didn't
break break down through the bottom of
this imbalance zone and even inside here
you know we're still there we saw some
more buying come in you know another
nice buying imbalance 1669 I had my stop
in at two and a half so it's just up a
point in a tick risk on this trade and
you know we got up to 25 and a half here
we traded some site that's
sighs we traded shows five and a quarter
you know we traded about 500 lots there
and you know it really looked like we
were going to go up then you know I only
needed another three tix to get to my to
get to my profit target and you know as
luck would have it in trading you know
people say is the luck involved in
trading well you know as soon as you get
in you don't know when the guy at
barclays is going to press the button to
sell you know how many thousands of
contracts and what happens you know
we're tricking here 65 boom within you
know that one that one split second at
846 if I could blow it out here but you
know all this this all happened in one
second this moved on from 64 and a half
down to 62 and a half a big sell order
hit the market and I got stopped out you
know it's unfortunate you know when the
app that's why you have to have stops in
the market you know everything you know
was setting up the way I like it you
know I got the buying in balance I got
long inside the zone the zone is holding
and some more you get a big vine and
balance here and we're starting to move
up to then wham you just get hit with a
big order and it comes right back down
and stops me out so you know I take the
loss that's all you can do and can't do
anything else that's why you have to
have have to have stops in there so you
know I was only risking five tix point
and a tick so you know and I'm looking
for a move up into the 66 area so it's
good more than a one to one trade came
down into the slowly this time we have
the divergence we have the ratio that I
like we pop back up up right back up the
66 before we came back down now I got
long on this next trade how long it at
three and a half it's actually off of a
10 range chart so this was my first
trade here this is the 10 range start
i'm looking at now so i'm getting along
off of off of this 10 range chart here i
have a divergence and i have the price
rejecter kicking off I got long if
just above this point of control here
this was at 63 I believe number arms 62
and three-quarter so I threw in a bid
we're going to trade all the way up to
66 and quarter but I think I threw in a
bit here at three and a half which is
slightly above this point of control I
wanted to see if this point of control
would hold mean it's okay if we get
through it a little bit like we didn't
later you know but my stop for this
trade is going to be down here you know
just below this low at 61 was the one
and a half is the love of my stop I
remember was that that one and a half
but then you know what what happens is
you know we just go sideways I got long
at three and a half on the pullback and
we're just going sideways sideways
sideways again you know this is a move
was looking for some work around the 66
and we were just going sideways in here
this bar that we're in you know had at
one point very strong selling they had
this big selling imbalance 2,300 yeah I
had negative Delta at one point of 2,200
we're still staying above my above the
low my stop is down here and then we
just sitting around in here and early on
in this bar you know starin at us
negative Delta 800 yeah I chose to get
out at yeah I threw an offer there at
three and three quarters because he
liked traded up and come back down trade
up come back down trade up come back
down it just didn't feel good in the
sense that you know the order flow
wasn't it wasn't there you know I had
this strong Delta in this bar here four
thousand even in the bar with my
trajectory had 2400 and yet for
thousands of articles lower then you get
declining Delta 800 400 minus 208 that's
not how I like this he dealt ago you
know I got out you know again is looking
have it I got out and then the market
popped back up literally you know right
afterwards but you know I didn't want to
take the chance and in turn you know
what could have been a scratch trade you
know like I got out of the tick which is
one tick it's not scratched but still I
don't want to turn the potential scratch
trade into a loss of a point you know
even though
immediately after i get out pop back up
you know I'd rather take the small tiny
there's the smallest profit you could
make rather than you know if I'm gonna
see because really we spending a lot of
time down here early was until later
that we popped up and came up there yeah
it popped back up to a you know six and
a half you know seven we can get we got
six in three quarters and then we fell
over so yeah yeah I could look back its
own should held it but you know honestly
and this was a a nice little pop up but
then we just immediately sold off so you
know honestly if I'm if we pop up I this
happened really fast and was going to
pop up here you know who knows if I
would have got out you know up in here
at six and a half I doubt it I probably
would have backed off a little bit up
and try and squeeze a little something
out of it up to seven and a half or
almost eight then I would have missed it
again then the market sold off again but
you know so in this case you know as I'm
not fine with it I'm fine with that uh
you know that just taking a kick out of
it yeah I could have got more but you
know who's going to be opportunities
throughout the day so then the next
trade was on the on the five range chart
and where is it's okay here we had just
you know so it came into this new low
here at 56 and a half I got a divergence
you see this triangle there you got the
positive Delta I got a ratio I like 32
it's above 28 and was a blue number you
know I got price rejecter and a lot of
things going on in this bar I got in a
bit aggressive 58 and a quarter yeah I
could have waited for a pull back a
little bit you know just above this
point of control yeah that would give me
was at fifty seven and three-quarters
fifty seven and a half so will give me
an extra half a tick or half a point
rather you know what I really wanted to
get in i really like this and I got a
bit aggressive so I got in a 58 in the
quarter immediately threw in an offer
the market's been pretty choppy a lot of
volatility say I quickly threw in an
offer at 59 and three-quarters just
because you know the way this market was
you know it can pop pop pop pop down
really quick this is on a five range
chart there's a lot of volatility with
that brexit boat coming up and it
happened pretty you know just popped up
there pretty quick and then it started
spending some time in here but this was
about a two minutes he laughs from the
time I got into the time I cut out yeah
eventually went higher but you know what
I got I got a point and a half out of it
which is which is good you know I the
first trader lost the point in it tick
second trade i gotta take back so you
know and net net for this day was these
three trades was uh was a half a point
so true kicks so it's okay wasn't the
best you know the best three trades
during the trading room but you know is
decent it was decent okay so thanks for
watching this video to learn more about
the training software using this
presentation and how you can profit from
order fo visit my website www or flows
com or subscribe to my youtube channel
got a lot of videos up there and you
know I explain a lot of things with
order flow so if you want to learn or
just go through my videos is there free
and you know you could learn a lot so
thanks in see on the inside